REED, THE FORMER U.S. MARINE
DETAINED IRUSSIA SINCE 2019 IS
BACK ON AMERICAN SOIL.
NEW PHOTOS SHOW TREVOR'S REUNION
WITH HIS FAMILY AT A TEXAS AIR
FORCE BASE YESTERDAY MORNING.
TREVOR'S RELEASE COMES AFTER
MONTHS OF INTENSE NEGOTIATIONS
BY BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS AND AMID GROWING
CONCERNS ABOUT HIS HEALTH AS HE
REMAINED IN RUSSIAN CAPTIVITY.
AND TREVOR'S PARENTS JOEY AND
PAULA ALONG WITH HIS SISTER
TAYLOR REED JOINING US NOW TO
TELL US WHAT IT WAS LIKE TO
GREET TREVOR FOR THE FIRST TIME
AFTER HIS RELEASE.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN YOU SMILE
BEFORE.
IT'S SO GOOD TO SEE YOU SMILING.
IT WAS GOOD TO HEAR YOU LAUGHING
BEFORE WE STARTED TAPING.
SO HE'S RECOVERING IN A MEDICAL
FACILITY.
YOU WERE ABLE TO MEET WITH HIM
FOR A FEW HOURS YESTERDAY.
AND YOU PREVIOUSLY HAD EXPRESSED
CONCERNS ABOUT HIS LIKELY
EXPOSURE TO TUBERCULOSIS AND
LINGERING EFFECT OF COVID.
HOW IS HE DOING?
>> HE SEEMS TO BE DOING BETTER
EVERY DAY.
I THINK HE'S SETTLING IN, AND WE
HAD A GREAT TIME VISITING WITH
HIM YESTERDAY.
TOWARDS THE END OF THE VISIT, HE
WAS MORE LIKE HIMSELF, TELLING
US STORIES, MAKING US LAUGH.
HE'S A BIT OF A CUT-UP, SO IT
WAS GREAT TO SEE HIS OLD
PERSONALITY COMING BACK.
>> JOEY, I MEAN, IT'S BEEN A
LONG, LONG JOURNEY, BUT IT'S
GOOD TO SEE A SMILE UNDERNEATH
THAT MUSTACHE.
HOW DOES IT FEEL TO HAVE HIM
BACK HOME IN THE U.S.?
>> HARD TO DESCRIBE, JAKE.
IT'S WONDERFUL.
>> AND TAYLOR, WHAT'S IT LIKE TO
HAVE YOUR BROTHER BACK AND TO
KNOW HE'S SAFE?
>> IT'S OUTSTANDING.
IT STILL FEELS A LITTLE SURREAL
AT THE MOMENT, BUT WE COULDN'T
BE HAPPIER.
>> SO PAULA, THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OBVIOUSLY PLAYED A
VERY IMPORTANT ROLE IN SECURING
TREVOR'S RELEASE, AND YOU HAD A
VIRTUAL MEETING WITH SECRETARY
OF STATE ANTONY BLINKEN.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THE
MEETING?
>> HE JUST WANTED TO WELCOME --
CONGRATULATE US AND TELL US IT
WAS MOSTLY BECAUSE OF MINE AND
JOEY'S EFFORTS TO BRING TREVOR
HOME, ALTHOUGH LIKE I SAID, WE
KNOW THAT ISN'T TRUE.
WE KNOW THE GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN
WORKING ON IT FOR A WHILE AND
THEY WORKED HARD.
WE KNOW GOVERNOR RICHARDSON HAD
A PLAY IN THAT.
THERE'S SO MANY PEOPLE WHO
WORKED ON IT BESIDES JUST JOEY
AND I.
WE APPRECIATED HIS CALL AND WE
WERE THANKFUL THAT HE LET US
KNOW THAT HE'S WORKING ON
BRINGING OTHERS HOME STILL.
>> THEY OBVIOUSLY DID SOME
IMPORTANT WORK, BUT DO NOT
DISCOUNT HOW HARD YOU GUYS
WORKED AND JONATHAN FRANKS TOO
TO GET THIS STORY FRONT AND
CENTER SO IT COULDN'T BE
IGNORED.
I KNOW IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
YOUR SON AND TO YOU AND THE REST
OF YOUR FAMILY TO ALSO TALK
ABOUT AMERICANS PAUL WHELAN AND
BRITTNEY GRINER WHO REMAIN
IMPRISONED IN RUSSIA.
YOU SAID IN FACT ONE OF THE
FIRST THINGS TREVOR BROUGHT UP
IN YOUR FIRST CONVERSATION WITH
HIM WAS THAT OTHERS ARE STILL
THERE, AND THEY NEED TO BE FREED
AS WELL.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO TELL THEIR
FAMILY AND TELL US MORE ABOUT
WHAT TREVOR TOLD YOU ABOUT THEM?
>> WELL, WHEN WE FIRST GOT TO
SIT DOWN WITH HIM YESTERDAY IN
THE EVENING, AND WE WERE
ACTUALLY ABLE TO STAY ABOUT TWO
HOURS BEFORE THEY HAD TO START
RUNNING MORE TESTS.
BUT WE ASKED HIM HOW HE WAS
DOING, AND HE SAID, WELL, I'M
NOT DOING TOO WELL.
AND WE WERE -- WE IMMEDIATELY
BECAME CONCERNED.
AND WE SAID, SO PHYSICALLY?
HE SAID NO.
WE SAID WHAT?
AND HE SAID, PAUL WHELAN.
AND IT MADE --
>> HE SAID I FEEL HORRIBLE ABOUT
BEING HOME AND NOT HAVING PAUL
HERE.
HE SAID I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
I'M HERE AND PAUL'S NOT.
AND HE SAID, AND I AM NOT DOING
WELL, BUT AS SOON AS I GET
BETTER, I'M GOING TO WORK ON
BRINGING PAUL HOME.
>> HE ASKED THE RUSSIANS, HE
ASKED THE FSB ON HIS PLANE WHILE
THEY WERE WAITING FOR THE
AMERICAN PLANE TO ARRIVE.
HE SAID WHERE'S THE OTHER
AMERICANS?
THEY SAID IT'S ONLY YOU.
AND I THINK HE WAS VERY
SURPRISED, AND WE HAD ALWAYS
BEEN CONCERNED THAT HE MIGHT,
YOU KNOW, IF THIS WERE TO EVER
OCCUR, A SINGLE TRANSACTION,
THAT HE MIGHT FIGHT IT.
YOU KNOW, NOT WANTING TO LEAVE A
FELLOW MARINE BEHIND.
AND OF COURSE, HE DOESN'T HAVE
ANY CHOICE.
IF THE RUSSIANS PUSH YOU OUT OF
A PLANE, THEN YOU DON'T HAVE
MUCH CHOICE, BUT ANYWAY, HE'S
REAL CONCERNED ABOUT IT.
AND THE DOCTORS AND THE STATE
DEPARTMENT, THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT IT WITH HIM AND LETTING
HIM KNOW WHAT HE CAN DO TO HELP
PAUL AND THE OTHER AMERICANS.
AND WHILE WE'RE ON THAT SUBJECT,
MS. GRINER, WE SAW A WONDERFUL
NOTE FROM HER WIFE ON INSTAGRAM,
A BEAUTIFUL LETTER.
AND OUR HEARTS --
>> YEAH, OUR HEARTS GO OUT TO
YOU.
WE APPRECIATE THE GRACIOUSNESS
OF HER STATEMENT.
AND OUR HEARTS GO OUT TO HER.
>> AND BEFORE I FORGET, JAKE,
THERE'S A GROUP CALLED FAMILIES
OF AMERICAN HOSTAGES AND
WRONGFUL DETAINEES.
A NEW GROUP, IT'S JUST THE
FAMILIES THEMSELVES.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE A PROTEST
IN FRONT OF THE WHITE HOUSE ON
MAY 4th.
AND YOU KNOW, TO JUST BUILD ON
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN DOING.
AND ONE OF OUR FAMILY MEMBERS
WILL BE THERE ALSO.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION KEEPS UP WHAT
THEY HAVE DONE, WHICH AGAIN,
THAT'S A WHOLE OTHER SUBJECT
ABOUT HOW GREAT THE PRESIDENT IS
AND THE STAFF TO MAKE THIS
HAPPEN, BUT WE WANTED TO LET
PEOPLE KNOW THAT'S COMING AND
YOU'RE GOING TO LEARN ABOUT A
LOT MORE OF THE FAMILIES THAT
ARE OUT THERE, AND THERE'S
MULTIPLE OPTIONS THAT THE
GOVERNMENT COULD USE TO BRING
THEM HOME.
>> TAYLOR, BEFORE WE GO, I KNOW
YOU WORKED HARD.
YOUR PARENTS WORKED SO HARD,
LOBBYING PEOPLE, MAKING MEDIA
APPEARANCES, AS DID YOU.
WHAT ELSE DO YOU WANT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO KNOW ABOUT
THIS GOOD MOMENT, THIS NICE
MOMENT, THIS WONDERFUL MOMENT?
WE DON'T GET A LOT OF THEM THESE
DAYS, IT FEELS LIKE.
>> NO.
FOR SURE.
THE THING THAT WE HAVE BEEN
HEARING THE MOST IS I CAN'T
IMAGINE WHAT YOUR FAMILY HAS
BEEN THROUGH.
I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT YOUR FAMILY
HAS BEEN THROUGH.
UNFORTUNATELY, THERE ARE A GREAT
DEAL OF FAMILY WHOSE CAN IMAGINE
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN THROUGH
BECAUSE THEY'RE STILL GOING
THROUGH IT THEMSELVES.
WE HOPE OUR STORY CAN OFFER THEM
HOPE AND WE WANT THEM TO KNOW
WE'RE NOT GOING TO STOP FIGHTING
FOR THEIR LOVED ONES TO BE
RETURNED AS WELL.
>> LET US HOPE THE STORY OF
TREVOR IS A STORY OF HOPE, IF IT
CAN HAPPEN TO HIM, IT CAN HAPPEN
TO BRITTANY, TO PAUL AND OTHERS.
IT'S SUCH A TESTAMENT TO YOUR
GREAT CHARACTER.
JOEY, PAULA, AND TAYLOR, THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THESE OTHER
PEOPLE AT THIS MOMENT OF RELIE